we are infinite exploration
earth is just one of our creations
when a child is born we unknowingly
create
ego by adding a bubble of separation
programming them for war against
ourselves we then go from room to room
seeking peace and happiness which we
inevitably find was already around
our necks the parable of the prodigal
son
is our best archetypal analogy
consciousness ventures outward
trying to find love in experiences
relationships substances it then hits a
breaking point
typically catalyzed by suffering
when it turns inward to analyze the very
act of seeing itself
upon doing so the programmed bubble
of separation dissolves
we become stewards for each other and
the planet
those especially in the greatest
positions of leadership
need their bubbles of egoic separation
popped to create the largest butterfly
effect
on our collective awakening
a human is just like a tree
the roots need to be nourished in order
to produce
fruits meet basic
needs worldwide to bathe in
abundance and actualization
zoom out see humans
like an ant colony the awareness
is shared this is what is meant by
god the witness
we are mirrors for each other in
collective
ascension gradiented from
dirty ego to pure enlightenment
there is nothing more paramount than
cleansing one's mirror
parents do the world a great service by
not allowing your child's ego bubble to
even form
starting at birth communicate infinity
to children that we are
dreaming this entire adventure
just to play and learn
each of us are a firework in
the infinite fractal know
your true nature we are
it the absolute
endlessly expressing itself